absolutely
[Music]
and what a lad I have for you today now
everyone I've spoken to about this man
has said he is the best lad that you'll
ever meet he's someone who's had a very
different Pathway to the top than most
he was working in the Navy as his main
job until he was picked up from the
Cornish Pirates and given an opportunity
firstly with Toulouse where he won the
top 14 and since Northampton where he's
gone on to be one of the stars of the
premiership right now of course he's
currently playing for a team that
everyone's fallen in love with at the
Rugby World Cup in Fiji and I like
everyone I'm very excited to see where
these guys end up so I'm super pumped
and grateful for this episode it is of
course the great man himself Sam
matavasi welcome mate thank you very
much I think it's the intro I don't know
how true I don't know who you've been
speaking to but people are lying to you
right I'm doing my own research here and
you're one of the absolute great
I don't know about that mate I do
appreciate you coming on like I know
you're in the middle of a Rugby World
Cup and you obviously are coming off the
back of a worm first time against
Australia in about 100 years mate what
was that like in the weekend yeah it's
an unbelievable feeling
um I think it's because I like every
team going to walk up in the build up
like we've worked hard I think we've
we've it's the hardest I've ever worked
with Fiji in a Fiji Camp yeah that I
think that's due to the coaching the
management the the planning but it's
it's been awesome now I don't want to
you know I think it's a shock people
call it a shock because we haven't beat
them for 69 years or something like that
yeah you know it is it's a long time but
I think if you're actually in the group
it probably doesn't come as much of a
shock if that makes sense yeah I think
the boys are quietly confident obviously
very humble but yeah we're not we're I
think our biggest thing is how do we
keep keep and keep it up I think it's
obviously very easy to get get up for
Wales in Australia you know the first
two games of the World Cup for us but
the biggest thing now is how can we keep
that going for the next two games
obviously last World Cup we lost the
Uruguay just no disrespect the Uruguay
but we pushed Australian Wales again
pretty close yeah it's interesting you
mentioned
um the shot because you guys are now the
number one ranked site in your pool
um probably the first time ever going
into a Rugby World Cup being the number
one ranked side in your pool so how does
that feel like what what difference does
that make if I'm taking all right I'd
probably say it doesn't make a
difference at all um yeah
I think for us it's it's just and it
sounds it's gonna sound very cliche
you'll know more anyone is it is each
game like I think we you'll be built up
Wells a lot I think we put a lot of
energy into that and rightly so
um
I think we should have got more from the
game personally I think we'd we played I
think we played better against well
zombies in Australia
um but you know it isn't it wasn't to be
but I think you know the week after we
everyone backed it up and you know we
beat Australia how hard was it to get
over that um Wales last like you could
see the amount of effort and the energy
that went into it you could see the
Heartbreak when and you didn't get
across the line to finish was it hard to
bounce back from that yeah it was I
think what like the best thing is it was
the first game you know and you've got
you've got three other opportunities to
you know to win which but I'm not gonna
lie I was
pretty pissed off after like just
frustrated I think is the is the biggest
thing like gutted frustrated I think
when you when you play teams at this
level and you know like it hasn't
happened in a long time you know if you
get beat by a good team you know are you
like you can take getting beat by good
team but I think when the margins are
smaller than yeah some decisions don't
really go your way that's when it's
tough yeah mate 100 in the whole world's
sort of fallen in love with
um the Fijian side red light how's it in
there like what's it feel like being
involved with that yeah it's it's I
think it's amazing but it's pretty
normal the guys are you know I think the
some stars in the team but they're
they're very humble people you know
there's not much I think if you if
you've got some some food some cover and
a guitar and some music yeah everyone's
pretty happy yeah yeah and that's that's
pretty much as far as it goes like I
remember we beat England um and I I was
obviously I was born in England and you
know very much English slash Cornish as
well as for June um but I should watch
it it was sitting at the back of the bus
and we've beat England and we're stuck
in traffic getting back to the hotel and
boys are playing like the game killer on
the bus like like those and they're just
like laughing Jack and yeah I think it
it just it's crazy you know because like
we had a week off after the England game
and everyone I was like you must have
been on the piss three four days to stop
and like
we had a few beers in the evening
and you know it was lucky enough that ex
you know some of the boys at the
families in the hotel because I don't
know if you've been to the hotel after a
Fuji game but there's fijians everywhere
like they're everywhere in the world the
dance club support
um so we have a rule we we're allowed an
hour we have to have an hour together as
a team so in the team room we have an
hour just players and coaches and then
once we have some Royal caravanaugh have
a bit of a laugh then you know you can
invite people if people can come in as
well and thousands come in
last week and yeah it was it was
incredible it's just people and you know
I think the great thing is you know you
see old players past players that you
know come in and you're just like wow
I've watched you or I've played with you
and and then the the Australia that's
right the fijians in the Australian Team
all came for some cover and yeah it's
great to see them I I play I play
fantasy league with the boys at Saints
and I was like I got a sour cream with
Runner value
I put it in a group of things like that
like
yeah on room oh how good is that and are
you feeling the support from other
nations not just fijians at the moment
yeah I think we're I think where
everyone's you know everyone's second
team I think if your home nation isn't
playing everyone seems to you know
support Fuji and I think I don't know
how it's it's amazing you know
everyone's support is greatly
appreciated and I think I'm obviously I
was born in Cornwall in England and they
seem to be all for Jean at the minute
or on social media
oh let's go let's go to say and I I did
read the other day like semia rajaraja
was saying that you guys are here to win
the Rugby World Cup which I don't know
if that's a different mindset to what
you've had
um previously going to Wildcat with Fiji
where I felt like maybe being happy to
make the quarterfinals or that might
have been a goal but is there a
different sort of feel going into this
one yeah yeah 100 I think it I think uh
I heard coach I think they could give
the coaches a big wrap you know I'm
trying to have to get the team on the
weekend but they've been they've been
unbelievable I think uh head coach
Simon to like uh the Glenn Jackson Daryl
Gibson Brad Harris Graham dues and then
the sncs I personally I think they've
they've probably made the biggest they
probably the hardest job and made the
biggest change you know we've I said
that we've worked the hardest we've ever
worked um in a Fiji camp and we had a
session in in Japan which was probably
the highest session I've ever done
and that that's on a Thursday before a
game
we're putting the Graft in and you can
tell you can see you know in the last 20
minutes even against Wales looking at
just you know still be fighting at the
end and and try and get that last try
Etc we're right on the line now I think
that the coaches to be transparent to be
you know approachable good like genuine
good people and to actually help or want
to buy into the Fijian culture and you
know get to know the lads a bit better
it's yeah I think it's it's going really
well it's cool to hear and if you've
noticed a difference between uh from the
Fijian players who have um had a few
years now with um the druitt and Super
Rugby yeah it's so much like it's I
think there's there's more there's more
personal drawer than there is overseas
if that if you know what I mean yeah
there's 18 drawer players which is it's
incredible it's incredible and I think
yeah you know you're getting messages
like who's that guy who's that who's
that it's obviously super Rugby's on
different times in the morning to the UK
and there's just
uh I don't call them freaks but there's
just so many good players yeah and I
think that the drawer having a you know
like a an awesome like a facility in in
Fiji training facility I think you know
they're working on the training pitch at
the minute but there's just so much
talent as you know and I think there's
actually a pathway now of let's play for
the Druid instead of you know going
overseas early and leaving the families
and stuff um I I I I think that probably
12 to the next 12 years six three World
Cups you know you might get every player
you know from the drawer which would be
which would be unbelievable yeah mate
imagine that that would be uh that'd be
a Super Rugby Winning Side unfortunately
for me at the Crusaders but would you
ever look to get to the drawer I I would
love to but it's a bit older though I
think I'm like I was just I don't know
if I would if myself I finding the kids
you know and to to actually live and
feed you would be one of the one of the
biggest like you know attractions yeah
just to say you've done it now we went
to we went to the Village
um
enough when we first met as a team oh 13
14 weeks ago now and I was like
wow like this it's different you know
it's a tomato to my upbringing in
Cornwall to to the Village interview
news is different and it's
yeah it's a it was an amazing experience
I called my wife you had to walk about
walk down the hill up onto the the bit
to get some signal it's called my wife
and I was like yeah it's different I
don't know if I could do this for the
week just being an idiot but it's just
it just takes you to back to you know
the you know what my old man did what
his grandfather did back in the village
and how they grew up and seeing it you
know we were 45 players and staff were
in like the Village Hall all on like
maps on the floor
uh we eat downstairs we shower outside
we're in the waterfall toilet outside uh
brush your teeth out everything and then
there's a gym there the pictures there
and we train and own people from the
village or come they you know took their
horns cracking cars it was it was it was
it was it was awesome it was awesome it
was cool ended you mentioned your dad
there so your dad is fully Fiji and he
grew up in Fiji how did he end up in um
England so he he um he was playing for
like the city and barbarians 50 of
Warriors at the time this is like 80s oh
yeah and um he he did like a world world
tour in the late 80s and they played
like a like Bristol Queens uh back in
the day and they went to Cornwall to
play Penzance whilst the Pirates
president it was back then
and they were Mighty to the team that
you know we ended up all representing
and that's what Josh is playing now our
team our team Camp won RFC a local Club
in Cornwall where they're a good team
um you know at the time they're a good
team now but uh they were like oh you
know which fancy company playing a game
on a Wednesday night
and they were like you know why not you
know for free beer yeah if people were
past these we'll try it so they've
played a game on a Wednesday he's gone
back to Fiji
and he got invited to tour South Africa
with the same Fijian barbarians but he
had a plane ticket come from Camborne
and he was firemen at the time I think
he was a bit of a he's a bit of a
bag back in the day in Fiji he was he
was he was he was farming back in the
day and then he got a flight over in the
late 80s so he went from the farm to the
Tin Mine like South Croft in mine and
you know he was underground I spoke yeah
and he was like I think when he first
went down he was he was scared because
obviously they were using like explosive
to blow up to try and get them the Tin
Mine and he's playing rugby yeah and
yeah he obviously met my mum fell in
love I had three sons and he's never
been back to feed you
oh wow that's so good so then you grew
up in Cornwall yeah and what were you
like as a little fella bug
no um um yeah no we had a say great
upbringing we played all sports you know
rugby very early Cricket football
and then lucky enough for us you know
all my mum's side of the family were
very sporty and everyone played for our
local Club Camborne so you know we all
went to play for them
um and my old man coached me and my
older brother and then my older
brother's team like that they I think
they they they dropped out they'd have
enough number so he moved to the local
Rivals team which is very true so
there's a big like rivalry Campbell Red
Roof yeah
and uh so when my old man was like I'm
not going in Red Roof with you so I'll
go and Coach Sam's age because he's just
a year above Josh yeah so it was good it
was a real good uh upbringing I could
imagine you three
um you three brothers in the backyard
would have had a fair few um battles
going on what was that like yeah oh we
used to fight like cat and dog me and
Josh cat and dog what's the age
difference between you two
uh it's just I think it's is it 30
months true bang Bang Yeah Yeah it's
close close yeah I remember we're
growing up you know we would we'd fight
that much we'd have like okay on a
Monday it was it he'd have the remote on
a Tuesday I'd have the remote on a
Wednesday it was Joel and then we were
just like flip because we'd we'd fight
over the sausage like the kid that
smoked like clothes and hiding each
other's clothes because obviously we're
quite close in age we sometimes have
like the same friend groups yeah and
then I remember one time like we were
getting a Mr cricket and like one of my
friend one of my friends would come and
pick us up it's called Paul menki you're
a great man
where's where's Sam and Josh would be
like no he's not coming and I'd be in
like waiting for the waiting for the
same lift and then he just gotta get in
and go
just things up things like that
um yeah
like to just I think until we got to
college where because we went to the
same college and he also Hears A year
above it's probably
around College time so what was it 15 16
that he like moved out and like that
probably stopped but before that it was
every day it's pretty much every day and
it didn't stop till 15 16. yeah it's
like it's no good for me with my boys
if we were vicious as well like vicious
what was the worst buffer I I think we
got to we got to a stage where uh we
were at a local Club just practicing
with the old man Joel and we'd fight
that much like usually with the old man
he'd say he'd only have to say a few
words and we stopped because we were we
were scared of him but he would uh
this one time he goes just fight then
you've been fighting that much I've had
enough go and then fight yeah and we
both looked at each other up oh crap so
here we go here we go here we go
who won oh where's me always me
but I I do know like I have heard you
speak about
um
the passing of um your mum I think
you're you're 13 at the time so yeah for
you that must have been incredibly tough
for you to go through at that age like
you hear people going through like the
loss of parents or siblings or something
but and when you're when you're actually
in it I can only imagine sort of what
that's like um so how was that for you
and how hard was that for you to deal
with
um it was it was it was tough it was so
so tough I probably I'd go as far as say
I probably didn't deal with it until
like we're in covert oh wow okay that
long so yeah I think
um you know this is nothing against my
dad and and our upbringing or anything
like that I think at 13 when it happens
I think for me you know you you
highlight you hide your emotions and you
know you you get on with things and my
dad was very much of the he was like you
know I want I wanted to get back on
track I think you should get back to
school quite early you know and I think
let's try and get you know not get on
with it or move on but let's let's try
and you know let's try and best of
encounter push through
and I think when you're 13 you know
you've got so many emotions and stuff
like that I just remember not never
really dealing with it
um or talking to anyone I think this you
know the school were very good they
they had someone that we could talk to
but um there's no respect to him he
wasn't saying as qualified as he should
be and I think it probably goes pretty
good as far as say it was it probably
hindered me because I just not 13 but
coming to like 16 well 17 18 when you
know I just got on the piss and trying
to fight everyone and all my anger and
emotions would only come up then if that
makes sense yeah and uh you know for for
a lot of bad reasons now during covet it
was it got to this point where you know
we you were at home all the time playing
um was it like quizzes and drinking and
I was just like you know I I need
to speak to someone and I was how long
was that so 20 15 years probably
something like that it was 16 years you
know since since it happened that I
actually
so how I don't wanna I wanted to speak
to someone in Northampton who didn't
know us in Cornwall didn't know our
story and just be as open and honest as
possible
um but just on the point I would I would
yeah um I think that but yeah I think
because I couldn't quite grasp at the
time that to with our mum she committed
suicide you know for a lot of different
reasons and I think that's the hardest
thing to take when you're you know not
any at any age but let alone 13 when all
you want is a Mum and Dad if that makes
sense yeah yeah I think you you just
want quick you know answers and you just
want yeah you want your mum really and I
think
you know this is going to sound terrible
but I think if she if she died like
naturally or you know I'm not going to
say in a car you know if she died like
where she didn't want to go if that
makes sense I think you you could you
couldn't move past it better but I think
you could probably grasp it in your head
a bit more yeah if that if that makes
sense it makes total sense yeah so I
just want to you know take the
opportunity now to I think if you can if
you can talk to someone you know if
you're in any state of you know talk to
talk to someone there's loads of people
out there that will help I think you
know friends family but people online
what was that process like for you once
you were speaking to the person in
Northampton like what did you go through
once yeah made that decision to try and
release it my wife my wife was
outstanding so obviously you know I've
been with her since we're like 18 so
like she's been through like the UPS the
Downs the ins and outs the emotions and
the things like that and I I think it
was just time you know we we like looked
at a few people
um picked one and we were just like that
let's go for it and I think the biggest
thing was just as be as open you have to
be honest you know you have to be as
honest as you can and it's not nice it's
not nice
being honest and going through things
and you know about yourself
upbringing and everything and um
but yeah it just helped me and you know
he was obviously he was Unreal he just
talked and it would flow and it would
you know I just come out with him
feeling so much less
stress and pressured and I felt a lot
more like relaxed and I think when I get
as frustrated or amped up and you know I
think it yeah it just it just helped
yeah and if you were in that position
again like uh what what would you have
done differently if you could have gone
back oh I would have I think I would
have
said to my dad I would have you know
said I I need to speak to someone and I
probably
you know back then you know not someone
from the school I think someone just
took to totally away from the score in
the situation and just and just thought
I think it would have been a massive
help
they're so that's so cool to hear
because I'm sure there's a lot of people
um out there going through something
similar or um a hard time so um it's
powerful to hear that coming from you
and um how you would have dealt with
that or how you did deal with it yes
it's really tough I I you know I don't
want to say anything about my dad I
think
in perspective you know he he was over
here with three young kids and you know
none of you know he he had my mum's
family but he didn't have his own family
that to like fall back on and he's I
think we're probably gonna we'll push
forward in in this chat and talk through
what what he's gone through since then
if that makes sense yeah and uh yeah
like you know I think if he had his time
again he lived up with differently but I
just think he people didn't really know
back then you know
um
yeah so but I think yeah his his way of
life and how he was brought up was you
know let's let's get on with it and you
know we'll get we'll get through it yeah
I I was only looking at the other day
when I was looking like my life
insurance and just imagining like
um how hard it would be for our kids if
um either myself or my wife the item
that's a hard conversation to even talk
about with my wife she gets all
emotional just thinking about me dying
yeah
um it is it is a tough one um
to plan and a tough one to oh I can only
imagine what it's like to to go through
so I appreciate you sharing that and
then what was your like um pathway out
of school like
um I I might my headset of being in like
electrician I want to be a Sparky so the
summer I left school I did yeah yeah
yeah I pretty average average grades you
know I was always one of them that you
could do it if he put his mind to it but
he was a bit too cheap like cheeky and
loud sometimes and
um so I left school that summer I wanted
to be a Sparky and the biggest thing in
in cool at the time was Truro college
for Toronto college is obviously they've
had some top players go through like
Jack Knoll Cowan Dickies people like
that and that was like sort of you know
the Exeter Chiefs and the Toronto
College was was coming into into play
and I got asked to go I was like no I
don't really want to do that
um went on again so I did the whole
summer work in as an electrician and
right at the end before I was gonna
actually go to college and and do one
day a week as a Sparky and four days on
site
I was like no I think I'm gonna go to
college so I ended up going to Toro
College
um went through college for two years
and it was
it was great it's crazy crazy we had a
good team you know we played every
Wednesday up and down the country and we
were having a few beers
at our local most Wednesday nights so
first Thursday night Zone it was a pound
of drink Incredible wow um it is
dangerous yeah
it's it's shut down unfortunately
um and then I got a I got I asked to go
to Exeter quite a bit in a week on week
off and it was it was all looking
looking pretty good and then I just got
in the piss too much and they were like
nah weren't you
I made a bit of trouble there and then
it was sort of Gone full circle so I
don't know if you you would you have
heard of Graham door English hooker like
a bit of a legend in the champ oh no no
it doesn't spring to mind oh if you want
to get someone on the podcasts you'd be
unbelievable at a different time so
um I I I got recommended by someone in
Cornwall to go and play for Plymouth
Albion because they have their
championship at the time
um against the Navy and I was like yeah
I've got nothing to lose I was working
in a local bar in Camborne I was like
yeah I gotta go and play
um went and played and he goes to me
well what your plans tomorrow I said
I'll probably go back to work in the bar
he said no I'll sign you so I ended up
yeah I ended up going to Plymouth Albion
I think at one stage I was the youngest
player to play in the championship and I
was like 17 in the back row
yeah and then I just sort of like went
up and down from Championship National
One National two I couldn't really get a
break I wasn't really working hard
enough and I was like
um in and out of jobs and stuff and then
my wife felt pregnant and I was like
I need I needed I need some I need
something else because Robbie's not
really going well I need a career and in
the meantime you know I've been helped
out by all the clubs in in Cornwall
right Campbell midriff
um yeah they were really good to me like
how can be a jobs rugby things like that
I waited like six months to join like
something like that for when I first
signed up to get all the medical checks
done to then to then join
um rugby was literally in the in the
back of my mind like I genuinely didn't
think I'd play professionally again I
didn't think I'd ever play for Fiji
again I wasn't really that bothered if
I'm honest I just wanted to get in the
Navy try and work hard and do well and
you know have a career
so I did my 10 weeks basic train in the
Navy my 12 weeks phase two training then
we got my first post my first draft down
at rnas Cold Rose which is it's an air
station in Cornwall
um yeah you know you're quite lucky
because not many people want to move
down to Houston and Cornwall if they're
not from there or if they're a bit older
really so I I got the I got the job done
there was was working pretty normal like
eight till four or Fridays off you know
up at lunch things like that
they had to do like a few a few shifts
you know a few uh shifts here and there
and um I get a call one afternoon and
it's Alan paver from the Pirates yeah
I'm surprised I've got his number but
why is he calling me
um he was like I'm not gonna put his
accent on but he pretty much was like
look we are we're desperate for hooker
our three hookers are injured and I was
like Hey they've got two problems I said
firstly I'm not a hooker and secondly
I've just joined the Navy I can't just I
can't just cover come and play
um so you'd never played hooker at this
point
so I I tried it at the Plymouth when
they got relegated from the champ to
National one and I've tried it for like
two weeks I think but maybe a bit more
maybe a month
and obviously if you get relegated in a
team and you just move positions and
you're not really playing you know it's
not it's not it's not that good a recipe
if that makes sense for success
so I I just like uh okay so he was like
look
we'll help you we need you like please
please come so I went and spoke to what
my bosses in the Navy and where I worked
and Dean Jones and Adam galately and a
few other people
um at Cold Rose and they were like look
we'll keep it quiet you can go for two
days a week go and train Tuesday
Thursday but you've got to be at work
three days he said this is off the books
you know like we can manage this so I
was like okay
and there was literally no one else so I
remember I came off the bench at
halftime against Jersey at home
one of my first game of the Pirates and
it was like quite an even contest like
Jody's a good team and I think I threw
like
six like six lineups that we didn't win
like three were like to the left three
overthrow and it I go as far as say is
it it probably cost us the game and I
was just like
so I I go back in Monday to the to the
review and I was I was strongly like I
was ready to be like look thanks Sam but
but no thanks like like that and um now
it was complete it's the complete
opposite like Alan paver and
um cats Gavin cattle were absolutely
incredible I think uh at the time with
paves he goes to the forwards
we need to work hard and I don't know
you obviously you've played at the
Pirates Avenue down at many yeah tough
place to play yeah
yeah so you think that you think that
the main pitch is obviously is kept
quite nice but the back pitch where we
train
um it obviously especially in in
December you know January February
it's correct it's like a it's a pig stay
down there and you know he says to the
forwards we're going to work hard we're
gonna do some extra scrubbing extra ball
in and I think the boys were like
stunning prick why have you come why are
we doing this
and uh yeah so that that for the for the
half a year that I then played you know
he he fully backed me backed me I played
most games and I think you know to move
to the front row to learn to throw and
to actually do it the best thing is just
being in it in it to learn and you know
you probably learn more when things
aren't going as well
so that was the 17-18 year yeah another
1780 now the 1819
uh I'm back in work and they're like
okay you can have a bit more time I've
got like three or four days now I'm
pretty much full-time at the Pirates
because they don't work on a Friday
so and you know I had a full preseason
um if things were going well and I got
picked for Fiji uh for the first time in
five years I got picked the game in 2018
and we lost to Scotland beat Uruguay and
beat France at the start of France oh
yeah good literally and then obviously I
had a few beers that night
um and I've the next you know and the
next uh the next day Sunday I got on an
airplane back to Cornwall in with the
Pirates
and at this stage I'm I'm sort of
playing three quarters of the year for
the Pirates in the last quarter of the
Navy because obviously that's what the
Navy fixtures come about and that they
were like you have to play it in the
Navy which is perfect
um so we've got a long story we've
played we've played the RAF at
harlequins on Friday night and I I get a
call
you after Toulouse tomorrow to loose
when I sign you as a medical Joker
they've seen you game against France
who's that who's called you
seriously
and the Navy wearing wow the Navy are
incredible the people in charge of the
Navy were like look we can't really do
this because he's not insured you're not
covered you can't just go to France and
play but we'll we'll let you but you
just you're sort of on your own if that
makes sense yeah
so
it's a little disrespect to the Pirates
but I've gone from having to buy my
aftermath shirt at the Pirates to then
being like I'm getting socks and pants
from Eden Parker to loose
you know what's going on
um and I've walked in that walked in the
changer and they've got the pond enter
Mac German kind of
teslie Colby and it literally was like
and they're incredible and it was tough
because I sort of I'd be on the bench
come on they're okay uh come with a
bench to come on they're okay then I'd
have to go back and play for the Navy oh
yeah but sort of like in into
interrupted it and and yeah and uh but
it was the experience it was it was
absolutely unbelievable you know
something I'll happen forever
um
so after that the Toulouse
we have we have a very good night out a
very very good couple of nights out in
Paris yeah like unbelievable was it oh I
like they think we had like a we had
like a our own like private plane took
up to Paris the place we stayed before
incredible we had a few beers before
because we weren't playing so like the
coaches and the players have been
playing went out for a few beers
um and then obviously we had to warm up
you know the next day but everyone was
fine you know I'm in the state of France
warming up you know about to watch to
lose to Claremont
and um
you know we there's a massive massive do
in in the middle of Paris after like
unbelievable we're going where me Richie
Arnold
um JoJo Corey Carl axtons we're
following Williams server around France
and obviously everyone knows him yeah
we're getting these random bars just
like
oh it's just incredible and then
wake up the next day we get a we get a
private we're on the plane back to
Toulouse like people are doing like the
skydives the tray that's been usually
pushed around which is free for all just
like count yourself yeah
um we're getting to like and yeah like
I've gone from
playing for the Pirates to play for the
Navy to then do in an open top open top
bus you know in front of thousands of
thousands of people to lose what a story
that's crazy yeah yeah like
so that that like I thought I've
still got a wife and kids I need to get
home so I go home so Saturday Sunday I
go home on the Monday and I'm home for a
week and then I fly to Fiji for the
World Cup prep so another four months
away
yeah and um last World Cup uh in Japan
incredible my older brother and then
when I came come back
and then I ended up signing for
Northampton
all right that is so crazy was it hard
to learn the hooker craft because
obviously um you don't often see Lucy's
go to Hooker and that sort of transition
to how uh work that quickly yeah it was
I I'll be I'll be honest I love the I
prefer I prefer the scrumagen I love it
people hear like what is the honor about
yeah
you you don't appreciate what how good
props and hookers are obviously unless
you know unless you actually
you're in there and you know you figure
it out yourself but it's it's an art
form it really is an art form and yeah
it's incredible you know I I love
watching like I've gone from a bit of UA
to love watching scrums and stuff that
but it's like it's like the the
throw-ins they're throwing's tough
because it it's like the scrum as well
but people if you see a bad throw you
just think it's the hooker whereas
obviously there's a massive like amount
that goes into a line like the movement
they're just like so much stuff but
people just think if you ever through
bad throws or you can Ferrari yeah yeah
but it's actually
it's obviously such a close skill like I
I'd rather have I rather I'd rather
scrub than throw yeah you know I've got
better now I think you know Northampton
have been unbelievable but you know
helping that along and trying to trying
to get better and things like that but
it's yeah it's it's like this
nerve-right it's quite nerve-wracking
yeah I'd be it made it it looks like it
and
um was it as it just rips that get you
there like is that the only way you can
really train it yeah I I think it's it's
reps because obviously everyone throws
differently everyone holds a ball
differently but it's reps it's doing it
under pressure against people I'd say
that any young hookers that you know
probably haven't got the tools it's it's
really tough because they just people
just pick a Target and just throw a
constantly at a Target but you know you
need to factor in things moving you know
you want to come like targets moving
forward moving back you know like I
think loads of different stuff but yeah
it but the The Throne has been been hot
I think it's more it's mentally as well
than it is you actually do it nice
interesting and when you sign with
Northampton was that the only option or
did you have other options coming at you
like why Northampton yeah I had a few
options I think
um
uh I spoke to Chris Boyd uh yeah and I
like I liked how he spoke I like how he
you know he he was trying to play but I
when I signed that Saints you know I I
pretty much knew I was going to be third
fourth choice if that makes sense just
to you know get the opportunity to to
have a crack and was that what is that
what it played out like uh at the start
yeah I thought obviously when a new
player comes in I got a I got the you
know uh I think I was I was on the bench
for the first two games got to start
went really bad and then like the movie
Another another four months and they
know that and that was only then it was
only due to injuries and you know other
other form I'd say to get an actual five
five six game on the bounce where you
can show what you can you can do yeah no
100 because it's been such an
interesting ride for you hey obviously
you were talented
um you love the purse sort of held you
back yeah um and then you get these
opportunities slowly and then um
obviously taking them throughout the
yeah right and then all of a sudden
you're a pro footy player did you ever
think you were going to be a pro footy
player when you were in the Navy
nah not not not not at all even before
that I think like you know I'm not
saying I was you know Richard McCourt
but I had a bit of talent if that makes
sense you know I was I was a bit
talented but I think it was having kids
that was like okay like life's changed
Now isn't just you you know you've gotta
you do a bit more and yeah it's probably
since I
24 on board so if I'm 24 to now I I you
know I if you were like did you work
hard for the I I would I could say look
in the mirror and say yes you know I've
I've worked hard if that makes sense
yeah
from from 24. now I wasn't an idiot I
could have done it at 17 16 15 it would
have been you know who knows what could
have happened yeah man it's crazy yeah
and was there any pressure from
obviously
um Josh had probably become a pro
already by then did you ever compare
yourself to him yeah I I could because
we're so close in age and we're like
we're we've grown up playing
um I think we sort of flipped reverse
now because like I was all I was never
jealous I was always proud but I always
wanted to be where he was if that makes
sense yeah yeah but then like on the
flip side of that now you know he's I'm
FaceTiming every day how's it going I'm
scam and he's wearing all graffiti kit
I've just given him so he's probably
pulled into it but um so in in the
England game he bought he bought his
wife and his kids up with my nieces and
they sat with my kids at the England
game and I just think to have Josh
around and I've just that I think you
know he he was proud if that makes sense
you could see that his yeah you know how
proud he was in the team in Fijian in
myself was was awesome yeah that is
going you mentioned that you played the
last Rugby World Cat with him yeah and
the one in Japan like what was that like
like we got on so well because obviously
we've never since we were like say he
left so he went to college and he like
bought it so like 15 16 then on to
in the next 10 years we haven't been in
the same house under the same roof for
you know more than a week so and then
we've gone to the World Cup and then I
think after the first bit of training
we've roomed together so the whole of
Japan I think even before that we ruined
together that's true and I said some
misses I was like you're gonna be
scrapping this could be one of two ways
on honestly and we got we got on so I
think you just you well you grew up a
little bit don't you oh yeah we got we
got we got on really well really well
and how did that World Cup compare to
um where you are now
um I think that World Cup I think lost
like is my first World Cup I'm still
pretty new to the team I'm not gonna say
I was just happy to be there and I still
wanted to do well but
like like like for Josh for instance you
know he's he's got he's one of he's one
of the he was one of the senior players
back then
um but then I was the one playing every
week so it was like our room was like
quite mixed if that makes sense yeah
yeah but he was he was incredible you
know he he always pushed it in training
like drove standards his attitude was
good so it was good to see that part as
well and what's it like being in that
Fijian team yeah
um you've spoken about it a little bit
already but
um being in that side like can you speak
Fijian no no the the boys mainly speak
English or do they mix it up no they mix
it up like I think because I've sort of
been around a little bit now this has
sort of accept me you know what I mean
come on who's this idiot who's like but
there I think you know if obviously
we're in a hotel in Bordeaux if if
you're someone from the street that
would walk into the hotel you'd be
treated like everyone else they're that
sort of people yeah um yeah
it's the environment's incredible it's a
it's a it's a happy it's a happy
environment you know there's
nothing's ever too much problems or
nothing's well we need this and that if
that makes sense you know we're we're
usually pretty good at what we've got
which is I think is incredible
um yeah at the minute it's a Happy Camp
I think a very Happy Camp and the
fijians are always
um generally pretty religious and it's
part of their sort of weak and process
are you religious is that all all part
of the yeah um yeah I I I agree I
wouldn't say I'm as religious as some of
the players in the team quite quite
openly
um so we pray every day we call it lot
tubes like a church so we have that
every day
um in the morning so we'll have it
tomorrow more than half past eight in
the morning and that usually goes on for
15 or 20 minutes but there'll be a hymn
in there there'll be a Bible verse you
know the abuse and Collective about
praying and stuff um and that isn't just
for players all the staff buying you
know into that everyone that that's here
with the team is is in on in on the
lotto yeah no that's cool that's a such
a unique environment compared to like
other sites around the world yeah it's
it's incredible I think that you know
this I think people are are starting to
see it on limes or see you know phones
and everyone's got a phone camera these
days but it was oh the fidget and the
singing yeah we probably sing about 15
times a day
that's why we're not too bad
can you sing because they are good
singers naturally
terrible I'm not I'm the one looking at
my phone from who's put the lyrics in
the group let's put the lyrics in the
group no but it just like I think the
other day
um Franklin he put a song in the group
like the
the lyrics and
so for the next two days on the bus he
was like cut the music we're gonna
practice this to be fair it sounds
unbelievable
but like so for the next two days that
like there was any music on the bus you
know any after training we always see we
do a hymn so that wasn't him after so
but the boys can get used to it so
things like that right so cool and what
about that what about the hakka the
um finby the finby yeah how do you go up
there or how did how hard was that to
learn no it was a little bit easier than
most yeah it's pretty easy I think it's
like um be pretty honestly you know we
the national anthem was in English and
until the last few games in the world
cup so I've had to quick look over that
oh yeah
um and and practice but yeah the thing
of these are I've done it a few times
now so it's not too bad yeah you'll be
right up the front I'm not a chance
in the back side in the back hiding
somewhere oh it's so cool to hear and
what what are your plans um going
forward for 40 obviously you got the
regular cap you're focusing on now but
post that what does that look like for
you yeah
um I've signed for for the Saints I've
got this year and next year you know I'm
happy the Saints yeah great Club great
people I think after that who knows you
know um
family's still young you know maybe to
experience a different country or you
know different culture if that makes
sense I'm not too sure how old are your
kids uh seven and six oh true oh cool
yeah so and I've also also in the Navy
so I'm trying to trying to get things
all together that you know trying to
work that out yeah which is is exciting
and isn't it something you'd look to do
post for it is that sort of your plan to
get back into the Navy yeah they've been
really really good
um really good really helpful really
about pushing and and you know exciting
for what I've been doing but I love to
go back in some capacity and do some
recruitment you know be around schools
colleges and say join the Navy it's a
great opportunity to see the world and
play sport
um hopefully that that will that will
come to fruition
um yeah and then obviously like the Army
Navy and the Army the sport in the Navy
is massive
um so I'd love to be involved in the
rugby side of it for you know for a
while tell it is that full-time gigs for
like um coaches and stuff for their Navy
rugby side yeah so it's it's all it's
it's all in the Navy so everyone like
obviously everyone's employed in the
Navy so they're they're serving in the
Navy and then they'll they'll get a few
months off a year to to be it yeah but
the environment's incredible it's like a
full-time environment you know in the
rugby player but you're in the Navy but
yeah you're doing like a rugby schedule
if that makes sense and I am Keen to
hear a little bit more about this
whiskey that I'm seeing
um all over the show selling selling
globally it's like he said that because
my wife and my because this myself my
wife my two brothers
their wives and a business partner from
Northampton um so they've got a rum a
spice rum that's we've brought out very
recently and they were like you've got
to plug it you've got you've got to
mention it I know I saw it it looks
unbelievable yeah so we were we were we
wanted to do something as a as some
brothers that uh
you know playing rugby and you know in
this environment for a little while and
you know we talked about doing clothes
or this and that and then when someone
mentioned gin and that was like this
being it's sort of been everyone's done
it and then they're like rum so we're
like okay and it for six months it's
sort of which is just the conversation
and then we talked to someone who like
accelerated it a lot and now we we've
just sold out of all our first edition
so already sold out yeah which is
incredible
support's been amazing yeah and it's a
big process there too I like obviously
looked into uh making my own beer and my
own Spirits as well and there's a
there's a lot to it a lot behind the
scenes in it it's a hard hard Market to
make it back it's real tough I think
it's just the learning phase of you know
you need to register a company's house
you need to get the tax stuff you need
to do like and you're just like what you
know and I'll be pretty honest
um
you know the the wives have been
incredible that they've they've really
kicked it on and kick-started it uh yeah
so they deserve all the all the credit
all the credit for it and where do you
see it where do you see it going
what's the ultimate plan the ultimate
plan is you know we have it in in
Tesco's in m s and nasda and shops you
know and it's it's there the whole time
um I think the
you know if it doesn't it will you know
we'll say we've had a crack we've had a
bit of a fun adventure I say fun it
would be a bit of a an event an
adventure that is different if that
makes sense you know
um it's definitely things that we we've
learned along the way that we wouldn't
do the same next time
etc etc massively out I loved it might
see it because it's so true like yeah
give something a go if it works
um you keep doing it if it doesn't you
just put um
find something else because what you
would have learned from that experience
that you've done setting it up would be
um you'll learn so much and you'll be
able to move that into whatever you do
next but I'm looking at it from a
distance I can't wait for it to hit New
Zealand Shores it looks incredible
no it's all it's awesome it's an awesome
thing also I think you should buy one
definitely oh definitely made up like
track load and start selling it from my
garage be your main distributor from New
Zealand but
do you still get angry on that when
you're on the person or is that all
settle down now you're you're a car man
you girls in yeah obviously like like
anything you know other things will piss
me off but no I'm pretty pretty calm
they're pretty calm
um
yeah I think it's I think it's a bit I
think as you get older as well you know
the the the the the times of I've hidden
it every weekend and and going as hard
just it just takes too long to get over
it now so yeah I think if you if you
beat England or if the England or
Australia it's you know you you've
earned you've earned a beer so but other
than that it's it's pretty much you know
wake up get you know get you get in the
ice bath get your recovery done and get
ready for next week
you're on you're right on but yeah I
know there is one thing that does
obviously make you mad when you've had a
few because I have gone to the Instagram
for some questions Millions came in and
the first one is what are your thoughts
on women using the men's toilet and the
when the airline is too long
it's incredible that was uh we're on the
piss and the ship in obviously in
Wandsworth and I was like if I walked
into your toilet and took a piss there
would be hell up I was like get out of
our toilet and people just like
well it's fine I was like no get on your
own toilet cute like you should you
shouldn't be you shouldn't be in this
one and it really obviously I had a few
but it really pissed me off at the time
oh that is good stuff okay who said who
set that one in that was Richie Ives
he's been he's been
a basic he came for a long long time
is is a top is a top man him and his
wife are absolute Legends
yeah okay next one who wins in a
one-on-one comp out of you Josh and Joel
oh yeah I'll take that you've easily got
them
Josh is retired now he's he's in
retiring mode
oh I like it okay next man how would you
approach techlinks to us over that's a
tough one
point this out he's yours he's yours
but you guys have some tough guys to
tackle that Who's the artist who would
be the hardest guy to take on your time
he'd be close we we at the minute we're
trading hard so we've pre-World cop
every Thursday was four blocks of 12
minutes full on and you know I think the
first it was the first game no it's not
the first game but the the next the
second and third game to be sober didn't
play uh he didn't start yeah he was in
opposition and it's like off the back of
a line out and you're like at the tail
oh it was coming in the scene you're
like you know
you don't want to look up and spot that
and then there's
there's a few there's obviously Mata to
uh to Albert tuisui second rows then
you've got a bossy I could I could name
him I could name only ten I think it's
it's get low get in front and don't feel
the best yeah it must be fun to play
with though those guys you know
following them and support like offloads
or tickle breaks coming yeah like look
before when you get up from a scrum and
then you've got someone going to post it
quite a nice feeling
right good stuff okay next one
um biggest change that he's seen in the
Fords uh being able to match it set
piece time now
um yeah I think you know I think this is
the staff who you you do you know an
Alan Muir I do he does ring a
belly yeah yeah so I I go to as far as
I'd say it was him in Campo uh campasi
mafu yeah Campo the The Legend Lucid
prop that Fiji have had I think it was
it was them that started the the mold of
you know let's change it let's change
the perception of fish being you know a
flare team and not having a set piece
and I I go as far as to say it was then
that started it and there's just you
know people that have come in on board
and helped out and on the way and I
think having players playing it everyone
playing at a top level in Super or in
Europe it's definitely helped that yeah
you can see it a like now it's at peace
time was always a big question mark for
you can you win your set piece to give
yeah you know the backs and the
dangerous Runners the ball that they can
um just do what they want with but now
you can compete at setpiece and now they
are getting that ball and
um it's good to watch yeah even your
kicking game I've noticed like big
changes in your kicking game like both
from nine and ten
um has that been something you guys have
really focused on
yeah I think
yeah you it's
the the things changing it like you know
you'll probably see you see that at the
start of the World Cup uh yeah France
New Zealand kicking it kicking a lot
more and he's like that now
I go I think Jacko and and Daryl Gilson
you know we want to kick you know where
all the pressure sometimes you know we
want to release that pressure but let's
kick you know when we want let's not
kick for the sake of kicking yeah now I
think as you probably know you know our
our first mentality is if it's on we'll
go well we won't though the backs will
ever go and you know if we can if we can
create a one-on-one or you know get get
to an edge we'll definitely try but if
not I think you have to in the modern
game you have to have the capability to
to you know box kick you know kick find
some grass or or you know kick hard to
compete but it's it's all changed yeah I
think if you if you want to win the big
games you have to have a kicking game
don't you yeah massively and obviously
you would know more than most playing
over there in Northampton although you
guys do play a slightly more expansive
um style of footy than some of them over
there
yeah yeah really I think our our attack
coaches that he's unreal uh Sam bestie I
don't know you yeah came across him but
he's outstanding he's pretty similar as
well
um you know let's let's have a go yeah
it is cool to say okay next one what's
your favorite f45 Jam probably
[Music]
what's what's the joke there okay
[Laughter]
okay next one is it true he's the only
Cornish Fijian
um I say there's
myself Josh and Jog so yeah I'm one of
one of three
yeah
now the whole um now the whole City's
behind you all that The Whole Town's
behind you now aren't they they're all
Fijian they are they literally are okay
next one is his old teammate Dan bigger
as competitive as he seems on TV uh yeah
he's I think like you'd have you'd have
um experienced it with with turns and
stuff at teams he's he demands you know
the the best and I think he's he's
someone that he doesn't care if you're
the best learner team the youngest
player in the team you know he will give
as much to the player that that
that ultimately is they're not mucking
up but probably shouldn't be where he is
or if he's had too much you know
um and I I think he's he's outstanding
for a team but I think people don't see
is off the pitch is probably one of the
best people you'll meet is
yeah he's got a terrible fashion sense
but he's he's a great bloke a real tarot
he's still wearing jeans like his jeans
and three trainers now how much cash
he's got scary but he's he's a top bloke
like one of the best
yeah did you ever cough a spray from him
uh I've had a few looks you know when
like I remember we do it I remember we
were doing a walk through so with uh at
Saints we call it like we call it Tai
Chi so we're just walking through like
an install yeah and uh I'm like my my
mind's like right I'm laughing with
someone else and like I think I uh
and like okay so like we've done an exit
lineup we're going to go to 22 to do
another line out and I didn't hear what
was going on next so like oh box kick
ditch pissing pissing around and he's
been like what the is that you know
and I was like this shout out
before I don't know I don't know what's
going on but yeah he's giving everyone a
spray 100
there's even um spray the coaches or
what's that sort of relationship like
with the coaches or is there a bit of a
barrier there no I wouldn't say he
sprayed but he would he would definitely
challenge yeah
yeah and like I think if you've if
you've got a hundred caps of your
country and you've got the experience
he's got you know he doesn't do it but
literally not trying to belittle people
or that but he he's definitely yeah
he'll definitely have a if he thinks
something different he'll say it which I
I think's unreal and I think um you know
a lot of the a lot of the players that I
think are playing with him now in France
and to learn that you know people that
played with Saints you know he's a great
player so he's a great person but you
know he does get he gets like that but I
think it's good I think teams need it
yeah I agree and it's cool to hear good
to get a little bit of an insight there
okay two more harder our best player
that you've played with
[Music]
freak like just yeah I I I haven't
watched it all but I watched a clip with
um Jim Hamilton and Ronan o'gara to talk
about talk about him
and he's just like yeah he's he's he's
special he's very special and I think he
was he was so good back this was 2018 I
played with him and you could tell that
he was yeah he was his next level what's
he like what's he like as a black does
he speak much English or yeah
to be fair like he he always he always
spoke in the morning you know he's
always happy to greet you you know and
he from what I from what I I've found
then and you know what I've heard
recently that he still was quiet and as
humble as ever yeah I can imagine hey he
always looks so calm and like nothing
yeah
yeah yeah
very rarely shows much emotion 100 yeah
he'll like he'll win the Six Nations on
Saturday and he'll be I don't know
having a McDonald's on a Sunday or
something just
complete opposite to bigger like total
total contrasts yeah yeah okay last
question best piece of advice you have
for a woodland listen I ask everyone
this question and looking forward to
yours mate yes it's been I've enjoyed
this today
um I think
enjoy it you have to enjoy it I think
you know people say that you've
obviously they've got you've got to be
serious at times you've got to work hard
because in in most things in life but
you got to take a minute just to sit
back and be like
it's in a bad life is it it doesn't last
forever yeah um you know it will soon
change and you know what you'll be
watching the next World Cup with the
next the next players and people that
are you know doing well I think just to
enjoy it enjoy the moment stay in it and
yeah just be be pretty pretty humble be
nice you know what I mean I think you
might treat people how how you want to
be treated yeah and you obviously do
that because you are an absolute true
lead and mate I appreciate you coming on
the podcast sharing your story what a
what a story it's been like that's an
incredible um Journey very unique to
most rugby players these days are
straight into like professional footy
from 19 and talk about their injuries
and stuff but you're you're um your
journey is very unique and it's awesome
to see you different on the biggest
stage um in World rugby at the moment
doing doing great things so I appreciate
you coming on mate thank you very much
appreciate it it's been awesome and if
you do need that distribution mate send
it to Waterland and we will distribute
from my garage oh we've taken over uh
worldwide
we're far on your top man appreciate it
appreciate it mate